okay so we've done a lot about Tesla on
this show I love Tesla they're electric
cars they're popping up all over LA it
is hopefully gonna get us off oil which
causes all kinds of other problems but
Michigan is now going to try to outlaw
Tesla or at least the way that they are
selling Tesla's that's right Governor
Rick Snyder has signed a bill that will
keep Tesla from selling its cars
directly to consumers we've got some
more info for you so Michigan is going
to become the fifth US state to keep
Tesla from easily selling cars directly
to consumers joining Texas New Jersey
Arizona and Maryland in all of those
states except Michigan Tesla operates
galleries where consumers can view Tesla
cars but cannot discuss prices take test
drives or order cars Michigan's gone a
step further and will not allow even the
informational galleries now I don't know
if you know about this but the Detroit
is in Michigan and we make a lot of cars
in Michigan so I'm wondering if maybe
the big car manufacturers don't want the
little electric guy to come in and maybe
they put some money that got the
governor to sign a bill to stop the
electric I am done with it seriously
there is um this is the type of [ __ ]
that drives me crazy and everything that
we do about money in politics this is it
I mean we have a good product we talk
about oil all the time now therefore
that helps that helps people that helps
the environment that could help our
foreign policy because we wouldn't be so
dependent on awful regimes in the Middle
East all of that stuff we got a good
product and clearly what is happening
here is the money from the big car
makers is coming in and saying wow
you're doing something electric you're
selling directly to the people we're not
gonna do it this is what happens when
you don't plan ahead when when
progressive and the progressive nature
of our world happens and you're not
ready I know by the way III fault Rick
Snyder the governor for doing this yeah
but in a way I feel like he had to not
just because the money partially the
money but also because you're not you're
not representing the people of your
state anymore there's there's workers
for these plants whose works for Fords
and Chevy's and Chryslers and dodges and
all the stuff and they're gonna go
you're gonna come in and sell us out you
know how much trouble we've been in so
much I'm trying to keep my job you're
gonna destroy my job and that's what its
constituents are saying and whatever
represent is just probably supposed to
listen to them
I mean states are just small versions of
countries right at least in our cars
that's what's supposed to be yeah but
then after then they have their own
little things in the way they operate
but you have to understand that the
world is changing and you have to be
ready to set up a system that allows
Ford Chevy Dodge to change the way they
do things so that you're not pushing
other companies out which is illegal
right and and then now you have this
problem so what you should do is maybe
right now be like okay we're gonna let
them in but you guys should understand
I can't keep out normal capitalism from
occurring in my state so you guys gonna
have to step up because these guys are
ahead of you so you need to you need to
change the system but you right now he
kind of has to accept it because they're
thinking he's gonna sell out every
constituent that lives there right so
that's that's a really great point
because it's a it's a philosophical
point does he do as the governor what's
right what is right which is allow the
free market to go and and this clearly
what is a good product
let it be sold in a positive way but at
the same time which would hurt his
constituents so we know what his answer
isn't and actually we know cuz he
already signed the pretty big what do we
do about this to help empower Tesla I
mean we keep seeing things like this
we've done stories on it things like
Tesla things like uber that are getting
fought against by the powerful cab
lobbies all this to Airbnb which is
being fought against by the hotel
lobbies things that are great products I
use uber all the time I know tons of
people that use Airbnb etc etc that are
getting fought by the machine and I
guess that's your point that for
progressive things to happen they got to
somehow come in and and almost through
the back and change things first before
they really arrived that wasn't even a
question but what do you get the only
thing that you can do to protect these
new progressive ideas and inventions I
think are gonna be laws I mean I
remember reading that Tesla could sue
the state of Michigan if needed but when
it comes to Rick Snyder you know this
man did it for his safety okay I'm on
Detroit you know they still walk around
with baseball bats and pipes in Detroit
he's before his also doughnut watering
right I get really thirsty
yeah dry spells and everything like that
so I understand the man who no they
literally shut the water I remember I
yeah that was hardcore yeah does it turn
back on you do you know I don't think
it's fully turned back on with that
that's a wholly hydrated so they're
angry and they've got lead pipes and
they might lose their job so I
understand why Rick decided to do this
but I'm reading the story I'm like are
we in North Korea or Communists and
communist China is a better example
because I remember when the iPod came
out and they didn't limit that in any
market and guess what every cell phone
manufacturer communications manufacturer
had to step up and play catch up to that
and that's totally cool and we're all
better for it
where is now China I went there I was
like me they can get a cheap iPhone
because you know they do you know that I
mean the our exchange rate is amazing
guess what they did not carry it they
didn't I mean because they want to
control that market for themselves and
now of course Apple has a place there
but it was all under their terms so I'm
you know Rick get your act together for
the people in the country of like we're
Americans we compete we when you happen
ilysm if you can't stay in and [ __ ] you
you lost we have this which taught us at
five years old you know but you know
what you got to win the game and if the
game is if somebody starts running
faster and you got to get in the gym
yeah you know there's two parts here so
there's the micro part which is him
having to deal with his own internal
politics and getting elected again 'ti
right he can't say all right I'm doing
this thing and then all his people are
gonna lose their jobs because they
didn't do the proper infrastructure to
go electric so there's that and then
there's the bigger idea which is where
we'd want him to be brave to get because
we have this huge problem with oil so is
the electric car actually just like a
symbol for a much bigger thing like if
we really want to change the country
that starts with oil right I don't think
he was thinking that big that when he
died he died just so he probably had it
has a lot of friends who work in the
automotive industry who wined and dined
him it was like hey buddy please I think
that's it was that personal like he was
doing no he doesn't a big guy you get
that good steak
he's not thinking like I do I like the
whole electric car thing I think we need
to be awful thing but you know what man
I still love a nice loud roaring engine
on the 88 Camaro that I sold that
shouldn't it but my 87 you want it like
hearing the roar if I stop my car to
goes yeah I'm a little bit depressed
yeah I'm a car person yeah exactly
electric and all of these other
manufacturers my last point is they they
they all have electric vehicles and
hybrids that they're developing so guess
step up guys cuz Rick Snyder can only
hold this off for so long this is not
going to stay
[Music]